so let's talk about it I know people who
I ask feel time but I love Priyanka and
you know this me too so cool but I
didn't realize I will be really I didn't
realize like how fast I well okay what
was your first date like first of all
well it's kind of a long story but all
so basically we we were told by a mutual
friend that we should meet and he said
I'll connect you guys he never did and I
got impatient so I direct messaged her
on Twitter and she she responded we
talked on you know back and forth about
a year on text and then we finally met
in person and it wasn't it wasn't really
a date or just met in person and went
for a drink and then about a year later
we went on our first official date to
the Hollywood Bowl to go see the beauty
the Beast live and just recently we
played there to kind of end the first
leg of the tour and she set two boxes
away from where we sat on her first date
it was very cool that's so cool
so what I didn't know that was y'all got
y'all got married pretty quick like
people I heard people kept going whoa
that's moving fast first of all stay in
your lane exactly I'm doing business so
- oh um no I think what you know when
you know you know and we heard that
pretty much from everybody when we told
people we were engaged but we don't you
know it was it was kind of magical you
know just within eight nine weeks we
were you know talking about marriage
within ten eleven weeks we were engaged
we got married in December last years or
one years coming up on the first when I
was doing the I was reading the
pre-interview this I had no idea that
y'all overtook me in 2005 well we didn't
I feel like I just got really cool no no
one cared about us in 2005 we were just
coming up and basically to get other
gigs we listed the other acts that we'd
opened up for but that we really just
meant that we were on like the outside
stage in the parking lot while you were
playing for 40,000 still helped us get a
lot of gigs after that so thank you we
are you 20% I don't
now you're on tour for real so tell us
about happiness begins uh yeah so this
has been you know quite the crazy year
for the family you know just a year ago
right now we had just started recording
music to get together again and you know
looking a year later we're finishing up
the first leg of a crazy tour and and
also the album you know happiness begins
but it all started with the documentary
which we call chasing happiness which
was kind of just to tell our story of
her childhood you know her father was a
pastor and we had a pretty crazy journey
in the church and then into our music
career together and we had really no
intention of getting the band back
together
but after filming for a little while and
kind of healing some of those family
wounds that were there from our years of
working together in the past we were
able to look at this with a fresh view
and and really kind of all in different
ways find our happiness and so we we
went for it and it's been an
unforgettable year it's been really
amazing that's really cool like not only
I mean I get like the fans are excited
about it but it's way more cool for you
and your family like that's a hard thing
to like I mean that's my road family
over there and it's it's hard to all be
together all the time especially when
you're elated I can't even imagine that
so that's really cool but this is really
special to share that with documentary
would you released it if y'all wouldn't
have gotten together I think so yeah I
think you know we had spent money making
it so we probably and I think it was an
important story to tell you know and
that was kind of I think the thing that
was to us so special about it is that
there was no intention to come back and
do this again the beginning but when we
actually just sat down to the hard work
that uh you know most families have to
do we all go through things that people
we love and whether it's the family you
choose yeah you got to go through it and
and and we did and you know we look at
the other side and we're all kind of in
the best place in our lives I know
you're all married now yeah probably got
two kids and and it's a beautiful time
and to have been able to go through that
with your families is I think we're all
really grateful and aware of how unique
it is and so this has just been so cool
I will say you have like um the most
famous family ever
it's like looking at everyone lives it
in your family tree I'm like okay well
it's good those kids are gonna be like
they're not gonna know what normal is
we're like you have some cool ants it's
amazing y'all should have written that
you shouldn't but you should have a
reality show I just want to see it I
want to watch the dynamic of all those
famous people one family that's I think
man might break up again if we if
cameras are there all the time no you
won't have to be on point do you have a
favorite song on the tour I have a few
that I love it's like picking a favorite
kid I could I guess I can't pick two I
upped it to my songwriting to that's
hard to pick one but we actually have
just come out with a Christmas song
which has been a dream of ours forever
me too it's my favorite y'all know a
Christmas album we love you back in the
day with Disney we did a few just songs
here and there but this is like our
first and a real swing at doing a
Christmas song with the same group of
writers producers that we we work with
the rest of our music oh I love
Christmas music as long as you come on
and do it I will sing with you when do
you start playing Christmas music my
staff will tell you I actually started
like two months ago because I was
wrapping presents and Montana we were
richer and I was wrapping Christmas
presents so two months ago it's like
September yeah never too early because I
was wrapping Christmas presents November
December really busy so I was having to
do everything beforehand and you did say
that you were wrapping Christmas I was
wrapping presents
oh yes that's impressive I do that I
start shopping three days before
that's my yeah my husband is why I do it
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this